all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four now remember
this is a kind of transitionary period
right where Jonathan Hickman stops
calling it Fantastic Four and he starts
calling it Future Foundation we'll call
it FF for short which is technically
what it's called so just be aware next
week it'll be FF volume one so just know
that so you don't think we stopped doing
Fantastic Four but what this video does
here is this focuses on the full power
of Franklin Richards and exactly what
he's capable of now something that we
kind of have to keep in mind and you'll
notice this as we get further into
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four run
where he bounces back and forth between
the Fantastic Four comic when he brings
it back and the Future Foundation comic
that he keeps going that the Future
Foundation comic is designed to be drawn
from the perspective of Franklin
Richards whereas Fantastic Four is just
kind of drawn from the perspective of
the Fantastic Four right so a child's
Viewpoint versus an adult's Viewpoint
and that's why here we basically jump
back to the story that we did at the
very beginning when you basically we had
adult Franklin Richards who showed up to
his younger self and then basically woke
his powers up and so what this does is
it shows the child Franklin Richards
basically taking that pocket universe
that he created in that comic and then
putting it in a closet and the thing
about this is that he kind of just hides
it away he doesn't quite know exactly
what to do with it now that right there
shows that he literally turned his
closet into a place of Infinite Space
because it's big enough to house a whole
universe that he made now we do get this
kind of three issue Fast Track right
where it's like there's the whole events
with the death of Johnny Storm Johnny
Storm basically stayed behind he ended
up dying to the Fantastic Four are
really really sad that kind of thing and
so he ultimately ends up meeting with
his friend leech now leech is a
character who is crazy underrated in
Marvel Comics he's he's not really
powerful in so far so he can like alter
reality and different things like that
it's really more of the fact that leech
can shut down the powers of anyone he
comes across and there's seemingly no
limit to the power hours that he can
shut down the most powerful being that
we've seen him affect was a guy named
basically Mr M Absalon Mercator this was
a guy whose Powers were arguably on the
same level as Franklin the ability to
alter reality and he was an Omega Level
mutant of course it was the actions of
leech that led to the death of Absalon
in the first place but that seems to be
the limit of his power so far but the
thing about this is that Franklin and
Leach kind of go on an adventure where
they enter into the closet so what I
want you guys to keep in mind is that
from this point going forward throughout
the rest of this video as short as it's
going to be all of this takes place in
the universe that Franklin Richards
created and in fact he's actually making
things in real time it's crazy how
powerful he is it's easy to overlook
right but like once him and leech jump
in there they end up showing up on Earth
and then what they end up doing is
actually crafting identities for
themselves right costumes they make
themselves into superheroes right
hyperstorm and kid incredible now
hyperstorm what's really ironic about
this is that hyperstorm is actually the
name that the son of Franklin Richards
in an alternate reality will end up
using and in fact he becomes a villain
and he's ridiculously powerful like it's
nut he's not as powerful as Franklin I
don't think to be honest with you guys
but he's ridiculously op so much so that
virtually any superhero or super villain
in the modern day would not be able to
hold their own against hyperstorm right
he was crazy how powerful he was but
what these two do is they literally go
on an adventure right so like these
aliens with flying saucers they try to
invade Earth and like leech and Franklin
are like Conjuring these powers and like
destroying these guys Franklin Richards
is making all this up as he goes along
he literally just creates these this
alien race out of nowhere right he just
fabricates it out of nowhere and like
destroys them they end up going
underground and instead of the mole man
being the one that leads them Alloys it
ends up being Doctor Doom they end up
facing off against these guys right they
manage to defeat the mole men and then
of course they capture Dr Doom again
this is all Franklin Richards just
making this up on the spot right just
using his insanely High reality warping
powers to just create these things
that's the thing to keep in mind they
weren't there before he just made them
and just brought them into existence and
so the crazy thing about this is that
while all this is going on you literally
have Dr Doom who's just like responding
to Franklin Franklin's responding to Dr
Doom so on and so forth and then future
Franklin appears right and he literally
asked the question what's going on
playtime is becoming a bit predictable
isn't it just Twisted versions of
everything we've seen before we can do
better than that right he's like I want
to show you something and so Franklin's
like okay so you basically have Franklin
Richards that goes with his adult self
and his adult self is like first off to
be fair this is on the surface
incredibly impressive right fully
realize earth like a completely and
fully realized Earth implied rules for
Behavior meaning you've conjured Deans
into existence and based on your own
knowledge they're responding and acting
exactly the way they would in the real
world and a suggestion of even physics
right like what you've done here
Franklin Richards is you've created not
just a whole universe you've created an
entire Earth that literally operates
according to or at least as close as you
can get to real world physics now for
those of you guys who follow Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers run
going into like Secret Wars in 2015 and
at the end of that story you basically
had Franklin Richards who was operating
as a universal shaper which is to say he
was drawing on the power of the molecule
man Owen Reese to create whole universes
and then populating those universes
based on everything that Reed Richards
remembered this is where this starts
right this is where that concept comes
from Franklin Richards creating a whole
universe for the very first time and
even his adult self says look at that
right everything you made everything
Franklin Richards you made everything in
existence and so you literally have
Franklin who's just like yeah I know
like what's the big deal about this and
his adult version and ask the question
well if Franklin made everything leech
what does that make him and the response
of leech is it makes him God right it
makes him this Godly character and so
the response of kid Franklin is like
that's crazy right like I'm just a
little boy with a great big huge
imagination and his adult self says
actually Franklin you're too close to
one and not enough of the other
literally you're a God with not enough
imagination right you're a God that just
doesn't quite have all the imagination
he needs in order to create things but
what we're gonna do Franklin is from
this day going forward every day we're
going to meet here and we're going to
practice right we're going to practice
creating universes we're going to
practice creating Earth we're gonna
practice creating everything in
existence so that when it's all said and
done yes Franklin Richards you will be
as close to God as any one particular
being can be so again this is a
relatively short video it's not overly
lengthy but for those of you guys who
are curious about how Franklin Richards
became so powerful and why he's able to
use his powers in such an advanced way
seemingly out of nowhere in the middle
of Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four run
it's because of this it kind of happens
off panel to a degree there if I
remember correctly and I'll have to go
through and read just to double check I
think there are some stories that take
place after the main story arc is done
that kind of come back and touch on this
stuff a little bit but literally it's
adult Franklin Richards teaching his
younger self how to use the full
totality of his abilities all of which
will become
ridiculously important once we get to
the return of Galactus but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later
peace